alright so the migrant Caravan makes its
way north right to our southern border
the Fox Nations Tommy Laren Fox Nation
comma that has hit the streets of Los
Angeles asking people what they thought
take a look
[Music]
are you aware at all of what's going on
at our border with the migrant caravan
coming in thousands of people coming
from Central America what do you think I
think it's a nice place to be it I can
see why a lot of people want to come if
I was living outside the United States I
would do everything I cook to get here
you don't stop this Caravan this is
gonna be more there's already one
building I don't think that the entire
Caravan is filled with bad people and
hombres we just can't have a bunch of
people crash the border that's insane
there should be some amnesty grants it
to them because of the travesties that
are occurring in their country you take
care of the American people first and
foremost reveal before we deal with
anybody else's countries and their
problems do you think we should have a
wall on the other border to stop people
from just coming in no there should be
no wall no wall a barrier is the
stupidest possible thing it doesn't work
because look at history look at the
Great Wall of China
there should be no walls in our planet
it's just wrong I mean imagine every
country had a wall how would we ever get
around you know move around
does it make you nervous about who would
be coming over here since we really
don't know who these people are no
because I really don't know who must the
people are that are already here god
Bless America and every one of you is
welcome here all right love you peace
out
quick programming note by the way Tommy
will be a part of the all new Fox Nation
first look that airs Sunday night a p.m.
right here in the Fox News Channel
actually I might even be on the Fox
Nation if I do it's gonna be big anyway
Tommy will tell you how to become a
founding member of Fox Nation and the
new streaming service